former Trump adviser Stephen Bannon
recently sentenced to jail for four
months but free pending and appeal is
now openly threatening Dr fauci and his
family with being quote hunted if indeed
Republicans take control of at least the
house in November uh in the 2022
midterms Bannon at this point is an
overtly dangerous and disgusting figure
in American politics truly sick here is
Steve Bannon fauci what is wrong with
our country that they want to go after
fauci they are obsessed and here is what
Bannon had to say on the 8th of November
when we destroyed the Democratic party
as a national political institution and
really end the regime by the way the use
of the word regime here uh totally
propagandistic and inaccurate the hunted
become the hunters the hunted become the
hunters so uh and you heard Natalie at
the top the whole fauci family is going
to be welcome to the investigation
why fauci's kids why are you going to
investigate fauci's kit what I mean
putting fauci aside for a second his
whole family the entire family remember
war room was taken off Twitter because
of comments I made it back wait for it
Christopher Wray and Anthony fauci that
their day was coming they but that has
nothing to do with fauci took us down
they took the War Room account I've
never been on Twitter they took the worm
account on Twitter paybacks across the
board and all that big move wow
retribution they're gonna hunt people as
retribution this guy is truly disgusting
I mean think about it being mad at Dr
fauci because threatening him got you
banned from Twitter first of all what
does that even have to do with Dr fauci
as question number one
but it's like a blame the messenger sort
of thing it's the most base and
disgusting thing and understand that you
know what why is everybody's why are
they on the right so mad at Dr fauci
it starts with something
that is typical of cults
fauci committed the mortal sin to the
Maga right-wing cult
he did not kiss the behind of the orange
emperor
he said hey you know what we shouldn't
inject bleach
that's not a good idea hey you know what
we don't have evidence that
hydroxychloroquine Quinn Works to treat
covet it's anti-science
it's overtly pro-ignorance pro-hate and
it's also contrarian for the sake of
being contrarian and there's you know
we've talked a lot on the program about
conspiratorial thinking we've talked a
lot on the program about cults and cult
members oftentimes the Cults promulgate
conspiracy theories and sometimes in
addition to the brainwashing and all the
different stuff there's a desire to be
contrarian simply for the sake of being
contrarian conservatives and Trump
supporters should be mad at Steve Bannon
Bannon fleeced Maga people way more than
fauci did remember that uh Bannon
fleeced Trump supporters out of millions
of dollars and is in the middle of
criminal prosecution for it remember the
whole build the wall thing give us the
money and then we'll build a wall
which of course they weren't doing and
they didn't and now there's there's a a
prosecution happening
the Maga people should be angry with Ben
and not with fauci who gave the best
medical advice based on what we knew at
the time at all points in time during
the pandemic
but no they want to hunt Anthony fauci
and this is absolutely a form of
stochastic terrorism meaning with a
large enough audience if Bannon
continues shining a spotlight on fauci
and his family hunted fauci and his
family hunted people in the audience can
get the idea maybe I should be the one
doing the hunting and sadly
Dr fauci needs full-time security
because that is indeed a real threat